[Musique]
rusé mais que vous voyez avec ce sourire
de débile c'est moi damien juste un mec
qui a tenté une fois dans sa vie d'être
à la hauteur
juste une fois élu au ca va pas pourquoi
tu t'en suis comme ça non elle n'a pas
les papiers en laye tristus et
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas les papiers
ou c'est juste un choc mardi avec argos
il se rattrape en rd congo ce qui
s'affiche avec sa maman qui montre
combien la frontière chambre haute
société russe tegra je veux juste aider
moi c'est pas permis sa sirène ucd il
faut reconnaître pas à saintes donc vous
reconnaissez être le père de façade mais
ça y est c'est bon c'est fait
car si il faut que tu nous as on veut la
même chose que bagdad et sa maman merci
d'attendre
comment ça on va trouver une solution il
faut juste qu'on se bouge le cul et
qu'on trouve d'autres pères ce qui se
faisait les traits pour graver des meufs
ce qu'on s'apprête à faire là ensemble
c'est enfreindre la loi
c'est de la fraude en bande organisée et
on prend pour dix ans et 750 mille euros
on n'a pas de père enfin leurs critiques
hop on s'en souviendra de ce jour là ça
va ma chérie à papa et je viens
reconnaître ma fille alia al jihani
qu'il est un génie
on s'est un peu fait dépasser du café
dépassé par les braises de scellement
console délit c'est celui de la
solidarité
j'aurais aimé juste une fois réussir à
faire entre bien jusqu'au bout quoi
milliards et mer sont cités à
comparaître
en voulant le défendre tous d'une au
condamné
ces femmes les seules choses qu'elles
veulent c'est des écoles pour leur
mouvement qui a fait des gens qui sont
capables de faire ce que tu as fait
pourrir
ouais c'est pas con koffi qui tape mal
et là je sais qu'au final c'est lui
koffi koffi
oui ah bah c'est pas lui alors
[Musique]